today on free pilot training we're going
to be looking at all the safety
regulations you need to know as a
Private Pilot
these are popular check ride questions
and they could even show up on your
written exam but these are also good to
know when you're out flying around after
you get your license
[Music]
thanks for joining me for another
Private Pilot ground lesson I'm Josh and
today we're going to get started with
one of the most important safety
regulations seat belts let's get started
by taking a look at one of the most
important regulations you need to be
really familiar with for 91205 as I've
stated in previous episodes this is
where we find the bare minimum equipment
that an aircraft has to have to be
operated legally now you may or may not
get asked a question about this
regulation on your written exam but I
can almost guarantee that you'll get
asked at least one question about this
reg on the oral part of your check ride
if you look closely at this rig what
you'll find is that there are different
levels of equipment that you need
depending on how you're going to be
operating the first and most basic level
is if you're going to be operating under
VFR during the day now I know this
should go without saying but there is
not a lower level that you can operate a
standard civil aircraft so these items
you see here are mandatory anytime you
go fly
then if we want to fly at night we have
some additional things that we have to
have if we want to operate legally and
if we fly under instrument flight rules
there's even more things we have to have
but no matter what rules you're
operating under you still have to have
these basic things from the VFR day list
and guess what seat belts are one of
those things on this list but let's take
a closer look at this rig because it's a
little more complicated than you might
think first the aircraft itself is
required to have an approved safety belt
with an approved metal to metal latching
device or other approved restraint
system for each occupant two years of
age or older now I know this is pretty
straightforward but what this is talking
about is the lap belt portion of the
restraint system I'll explain the
shoulder harnesses more in a second but
as you can see here the lap belt is
required to be installed in each spot
where you have a human being sitting in
the aircraft it doesn't matter what year
the aircraft was made you have to have
one of these for every occupant over two
years old the shoulder harnesses on the
other hand are a different story
basically if your airplane was made
after December 12 1986 that aircraft is
required to have an approved shoulder
harness or restraint system in every
seat carrying a person if the airplane
was made after July 18 1978 but before
December 12 1986 only the front seats
are required to have shoulder harnesses
or restraint systems and anytime on July
18 1978 and before you do not have to
have shoulder harnesses installed at all
but once again you must have the lap
belt installed now no one's going to
expect you to remember all these dates
but be sure you know where all these
dates are found and once again that's in
91 205. now that we know what's required
to be installed on the aircraft let's
take a look at how we're required to use
those systems for this we need to turn
over to far 91107 the seat belt
regulation as you can see here before we
can take off the pilot in command is
required to make sure that everyone on
board word is briefed on how to fasten
and unfasten their safety belt and
shoulder harness if there's one
installed now it doesn't specify how you
need to do that but this is required
anytime you go fly with other people on
board and notice that it says you need
to make sure that everyone on board is
breathed it doesn't just say to ensure
that the passengers are breathed so when
you go up for your check ride be sure to
include that in your briefing for
passengers who have never flown before
you may have to physically show them how
to use these things works just like a
car seat and also you can pull it to
tighten it
if need to be although he's right at the
max on it but uh in an unclip it to undo
it and it's a pretty simple process but
for your check ride I just recommend
asking something like this do you know
how to use these seat belts and shoulder
harnesses if not I'd be happy to show
you seat belt briefing complete you
don't have to do the full flight
attendant demo or anything like that but
the reg doesn't stop there if you
continue to read what you'll find is
that in addition to giving everyone on
board a proper briefing you're also
required to notify everyone on board to
fasten their seat belts and shoulder
harnesses before any movement on the
surface before you take off and before
you land in addition to that before you
can do any of these things everyone on
Board needs to be in an approved seat or
birth and have their seat belt properly
fastened now for my friends out there
who are wondering what the heck of birth
is that's basically a little bed that
they have on airplanes and ships
sometimes that'd be awesome to have
something like that wouldn't it anyway
the Big takeaway here is that everyone
on board the aircraft needs to be
properly buckled before we can move on
the surface take off or land in other
words taxi takeoff and Landing now there
are a few exceptions to this rule
children under the age of two do not
have to be buckled as long as they're
being held by an adult who is properly
buckled you can also put them in an
approved child restraint device and I
know this sounds like a medieval torture
device but I assure you that it's not
it's a real thing that's probably much
safer than letting him sit on Grandma's
lap but nobody wants to hear a bunch of
screaming kids so we let them sit on an
adult's lap I'm guessing that's the real
reason why we allow that but I digress
in addition to the lap children there's
another group of people that don't have
to wear their seat belts or shoulder
harnesses if you're engaging in sport
parachuting in other words skydiving
you're most likely going to be using the
floor of the aircraft as a seat in this
case you don't have to wear a seat belt
maybe someday I'll try that I don't know
it seems sketchy I know we've already
talked about a lot of information but
we're not quite done with seat belts yet
there's a few more requirements for crew
members over in Far 91 105. during
takeoff and landing and while in Rood
each required flight crew member shall
be at the crew member station unless the
absence is necessary to perform duties
in connection with the operation of the
aircraft or in connection with
physiological needs this means that
while you're out flying around you
cannot get out of your seat unless it's
absolutely required for the operation of
the aircraft or unless you need to go
relieve yourself with that Taco Bell you
had before takeoff
in addition to that crew members must
keep their safety belt fast and while at
the crew member station so technically
you need to have your lap belt fastened
for the entire time you're out flying
around
with that in mind the shoulder harnesses
are a little bit different according to
91 105 crew members only have to wear
the shoulder harnesses during takeoff
and Landing now I do want to point out
that the reg does say that if your
aircraft is not equipped with shoulder
harnesses then you don't have to wear
one but notice that there are no dates
in this regulation that's because a lot
of older aircraft have had shoulder
harnesses added after the reg was
created and if your aircraft has a
shoulder harness installed you have to
wear it during takeoff and Landing this
Cessna 172h was built in 1966 so it was
built before 1978. at some point in time
one of the owners had shoulder harnesses
installed and now that they've been
installed in the front seats we are
required to use those with that in mind
91105 does say that you don't have to
wear the shoulder harnesses if it's
going to make it where you're unable to
perform your required duties with the
shoulder harness fastened I know that
there are a lot of Pilots out there who
take this as a license to not wear the
shoulder harness but I want to show you
something in Far 91 to a 5. shoulder
harnesses installed in flight crew
stations must permit the flight crew
member when seated and with the safety
belt and shoulder harness fastened to
perform all functions necessary for
flight operation this means that the
shoulder harness manufacturer must
design the shoulder harness so that it
cannot interfere with your required
duties so I'm going to tell you right
now that if you get caught not wearing
your shoulder harness on takeoff and
Landing I can almost guarantee you that
this excuse is not going to work okay I
think that's enough about seat belts but
before we move on let's talk about a few
more pieces of required equipment that
you'll find in 91205 first if you're
operating an aircraft for hire and
you're going to be flying Beyond gliding
distance from the shore you need to have
a proof flotation gear readily available
to each occupant on the aircraft and you
also need to have at least one
pyrotechnic signaling device aboard the
aircraft I know a lot of you guys may
not be operating For Hire but even if
you're not it would still be a good idea
to follow this rule because no one ever
play plans on making a water landing I
can't even imagine ditching an aircraft
miles from Shore and trying to swim the
whole way without any kind of flotation
device
out
where's that well done with that in mind
if you are going to be flying over large
bodies of water this would also be a
good time to consider how far your
aircraft is capable of gliding if you
were to lose an engine typically you'll
find this information in the performance
section of your poh okay I've got to
know who puts a giant plain silhouette
right in the middle of a Precision chart
I don't know why they do this but as you
can see here Cessna 172s tend to Glide
at about a 1 to 10 ratio so that means
for every thousand feet of altitude
we'll Glide about 1.5 nautical miles so
if I'm at 2000 feet and I'm more than
three miles away from Land I should
really have life jackets on board the
aircraft another required piece of
safety equipment that you'll find in 91
205 is the elt or emergency locator
transmitter this device is required for
most general aviation aircraft and it's
designed to help locate an aircraft that
has crashed the emergency locator
transponder is activated by high
g-forces to the aircraft so if you
exceed these forces by crashing or if
you have a really hard Landing it can
activate this thing and when this guy
activates it sends the most annoying
audio tone to the emergency radio
frequencies
see I told you it was annoying but
anyway on older aircraft that have old
analog elts when this thing gets
activated the signal transmits on 121.5
which is the civilian emergency
frequency and on 243.0 which is the
military emergency frequency by the way
sometimes you'll hear these frequencies
referred to as guard or the guard
frequencies and in case you didn't
already notice 243.0 is exactly double
of 121.5 that's a pro tip for
remembering these on the written exam if
you pass a written test by one question
and this was one of them all you have to
do is buy a hat or t-shirt from me to
say thank you you'll be thinking
yourself really but anyway if you set
this thing off everyone monitoring guard
is going to hear the signal ATC is
required to monitor these frequencies
and in addition to that most military
aircraft monitor 243.0 when they're out
flying around and if you want you can
monitor 121.5 when your buddy flies his
first solo so you can make fun of him
when he has a hard landing and sets this
thing off
with that in mind there is a newer
digital elt that slowly started to take
the place of these old analog systems if
one of these guys is activated they'll
send a signal out on 406 megahertz and
this will be picked up by satellite the
best part about this new system is that
it can also transmit your tail number
aircraft type location and even the
aircraft owner's name to the authorities
and that makes search and rescue a lot
faster and easier
in addition to that because these
satellites are up in the sky they're way
more likely to receive a signal since
you don't have to worry about line of
sight with a radio tower or another
aircraft in the area before we move on
there are a few more things you should
know about elts in far 91207 but
probably the most important thing that
you should be aware of is that the elt
needs to be inspected every 12 calendar
months and because of that this
inspection is usually done with the
annual inspection so this is where most
mechanics document that the inspection
was completed but sometimes you'll find
it documented somewhere else
91207 has a complete list of what the
amp mechanic is required to check but a
few things that he's looking for is
proper insulation operation of the crash
sensor and battery corrosion and
speaking of the battery here's something
super important you need to remember the
elt battery needs to be either recharged
or replaced anytime 50 percent of its
useful life is expired or if the
transmitter has been in use for more
than one cumulative hour
that's why a lot of people check to make
sure that their elt is not going off
when they secure the aircraft
by tuning your radio to 121.5 and making
sure you don't hear
sorry I've just had my eardrums blasted
out so many times I'm just trying to
pass on a true Aviation tradition you
may also consider checking 121.5 if you
had a hard Landing because if you
activate it and you continue to fly
around for an hour then the battery will
need to be recharged or replaced if
you're concerned that you might have
activated one of the newer elts most of
the time they'll have some kind of light
or alarm to let you know that they've
been activated so that makes it kind of
nice I guess
now there may be times when you want to
make sure that the elt is working
properly maybe you've had a really hard
landing and you think it should have
gone off but it didn't
you are allowed to test the older analog
systems make sure they're working
properly but there's a specific time
that you have to do that you're only
allowed to test these things five
minutes after every hour if you do it
any other time ATC is probably going to
send a search and rescue party after you
the newer digital systems are a little
more complicated so they really should
only be tested by approved technicians
while we're on the dreary subject of
crashing I think now is a good time to
talk about accident and incident
reporting now this stuff actually has
its own regulation that information is
in part 830 and there's not a ton of
information in here but what you'll find
is that the NTSB needs to be notified
anytime an aircraft is involved in an
accident or anytime a certain incident
occurs first things first let's talk
about the difference in an accident or
an incident an accident would be
anything that causes Serious injury or
death to a human being while on an
aircraft it could also be something that
causes substantial damage to an aircraft
or a combination of the two this can be
anything from an actual airplane crash
to a bad landing where someone on Board
gets seriously injured
now this regulation explains in detail
the exact definition of serious injury
and substantial damage so if you need
that information you can really easily
find it in this document it's only seven
pages long
an incident on the other hand is
something that affects the safe
operation of an aircraft but it doesn't
really qualify as an accident we'll look
at some examples of an incident here in
a second
now if you're unlucky enough to have an
accident you are required to notify the
mtsb or national Transportation safety
board immediately once you notify them
they'll typically ask for a written
report that must be submitted within 10
days
but if you have an incident you only
need to notify the NTSB if it's on their
list in part 830.5 if it's on this list
you need to notify him immediately for
those as well here are a few incidents
where they want immediate notification a
flight control system malfunction or
failure
ill crew members that become unable to
perform their normal flight duties
failure of any internal turbine engine
component that results in the Escape of
debris other than out of the exhaust
path
an in-flight fire an aircraft Collision
in flight
release of all or a portion of a
propeller blade from an aircraft
excluding release cost solely by ground
contact
an aircraft is overdue and is believed
to be involved in an accident
once again the complete list is in part
830.5 but if you have an incident and
you think it might qualify this is where
you need to look if it's on this list
you need to notify the NTSB immediately
and if they request a written report you
have 10 days to turn that in as well but
you only have to submit the report if
they request it
now for some reason you have an accident
or an incident on this list it's
possible that the NTSB will send someone
out to investigate the scene you should
do everything possible to keep it the
way you found it you should only move
the wreckage if you need to do so to
protect it from further damage now one
other thing that's going to help make it
easier for the search and rescue teams
the FAA and the NTSB is to make sure
that your address is up to date in the
FAA system in fact according to far 6160
you're required to change your address
within 30 days when you move to a new
address if you don't you are not allowed
to exercise your pilot privileges until
you do that and you can update that on
faa.gov or if you're old school you can
still send a written request to this
address right here okay enough about
accidents let's talk about oxygen
requirements for a little bit when do we
need to carry or use supplemental oxygen
when we're in an aircraft well oxygen is
required when there's a risk of hypoxia
now I plan to discuss this more in a
separate episode but hypoxia is
basically a loss of oxygen to the body
so at higher altitudes we're at a
greater risk of getting hypoxic and this
can affect our ability to do different
tasks because of that the FAA has
developed a regulation that's designed
to keep you from choking yourself out at
high altitude I said joke yourself
basically at any cabin altitude at 12
500 feet MSL and Below you don't have to
have anything if you pass out from
hypoxia you probably have something else
going on with your body and you probably
shouldn't be flying to begin with
now I do want to point out that this is
a cabin altitude of 12 500 feet and
below if you're flying a non-pressurized
aircraft like 99.9 percent of training
aircraft cabin altitude equals your true
altitude but if you ever start flying an
aircraft with a pressurized cabin this
is going to be different with that in
mind at cabin altitudes above 12 500
feet MSL and all the way up to 14 000
feet if you're going to be flying up
there for more than 30 minutes the
minimum flight crew needs to have and
use supplemental oxygen while you're up
at those altitudes
if you're flying at a cabin altitude
above 14 000 feet the minimum flight
crew must use that oxygen the entire
time
now up to this point you might have
noticed that we haven't even discussed
passengers at all yep that's correct
there is no requirement for you to
provide oxygen to your passengers at the
altitudes we just discussed I guess no
one really cares if your passengers pass
out but the second you fly above a cabin
altitude of 15 000 feet MSL at that
point you have to provide every occupant
on board the aircraft with supplemental
oxygen so I guess the moral of this
story is that passengers aren't really
essential to a safe flight so no you
don't have to provide them with
supplemental oxygen unless you're flying
at a cabin altitude above 15 000 feet
but I personally would Reserve cabin
altitudes above 12 500 feet for
passengers I don't really like now if
you move on to pressurized aircraft
you'll find some additional info over in
91-11 so if you need that information go
check it out after this video
since we're on the subject of altitude
now that you know what you need to fly
at high altitudes let's take a look at
some of the lowest altitudes you can fly
the details on this information are in
Far 91 119 but I'll give you the general
scoob first things first no matter where
you are you cannot fly an aircraft at an
altitude where you can't make a safe
emergency landing if you lose an engine
now this doesn't apply if you're taking
off or Landing with that in mind a safe
emergency landing means that you cannot
create an undo Hazard to persons or
property on the surface let's pause here
and talk about this for a second first
of all the reg specifically says undo
Hazard to persons or property on the
surface I'm not telling you to be stupid
about this but this is something to
consider with that in mind this reg
seems to be a catch-all to keep you from
flying too low but I just want to point
out that if you're flying at a low
altitude but you're also flying at a
high air speed you have the ability to
trade your AirSpeed for altitude if
you've never done this before I highly
recommend trying it sometime with your
instructor and you don't have to
practice this maneuver at a low altitude
but practicing this allows you to see
how much altitude you could potentially
gain if you suddenly lose an engine for
some reason this maneuver is called a
zoom climb and it could potentially buy
you some time if you ever lose an engine
it can be the difference in landing
somewhere that you don't want and
landing in a nice soft field
okay in addition to the faa's catch-all
regulation if you fly over congested
areas you may not fly less than a
thousand feet above the highest obstacle
within a 2000 feet radius from the
aircraft
here's what the FAA considers a
congested area basically any congested
area of a city town or settlement or
over any open-air assembly of persons if
you're unsure what exactly a congested
area is the VFR sectional depicts
congested areas of a city or town in
yellow and this would be a good thing to
look at if you're going to be flying low
next we have other than congested areas
in these areas you cannot operate less
than 500 feet above the surface unless
you're flying over water or sparsely
populated areas in these areas there's
no minimum altitude but you cannot fly
closer than 500 feet to any person
vessel vehicle or structure once again
the only exception to the last couple
requirements is when you're taking off
or Landing if you're taking off or
Landing you are allowed to get closer
than 500 feet on some of these things
but please use common sense and good
safety practices when you do that now
there's actually another regulation that
goes hand in hand with those men's safe
altitudes that you find in 9119 did you
know that you can actually legally drop
stuff out of an aircraft yep I know it
seems crazy but as long as you follow
the guidance in Far 9115 it is possible
to do it legally
all it says in this rig is that no pilot
in command of a civil aircraft may allow
any object to be dropped from that
aircraft in Flight that creates a hazard
to persons or property however this
section does not prohibit the dropping
of any object if reasonable precautions
are taken to avoid injury or damage to
persons or property so as long as you
take reasonable precautions you can drop
stuff out of your aircraft the next
thing we need to talk about is drug and
alcohol usage
even if you're like me and you don't
drink you really still need to know this
information because you could get asked
about it on your check ride or your
written exam but in addition to that if
you have a passenger that gets involved
with these things there's some things
you should know about that for our 9117
is the reg for this topic first of all
no person may act or attempt to act as a
crew member of an aircraft if they'd
consumed any alcohol within the last
eight hours so that's eight hours from
the time you touch the bottle to the
time you touch the throttle now with
that in mind there's a catch-all on this
rig it says here that you can't even be
under the influence of alcohol
so if you're hungover you cannot fly
even if it's been more than eight hours
drugs are also a big No-No you cannot
use any drug that affects your faculties
in any way that is contrary to safety if
Tylenol affects your faculty's contrary
to safety you cannot fly after you've
taken that in addition to that if your
blood alcohol is .04 or greater you are
not allowed to fly an aircraft for those
of you who don't know that's half the
legal limit in Most states for driving a
vehicle and there's a really good reason
for that when you fly at higher
altitudes the effects of drugs and
alcohol are way worse so it's best not
to take any chances when you plan on
flying now you may think that no one's
going to be out there checking to make
sure that you're sober when you're out
flying but any law enforcement officer
can force you to take a breathalyzer or
a blood test and you as a pilot are
required to take it remember alcohol can
be detected in the blood and breath more
than three hours after you've consumed
it and if you get convicted I can almost
guarantee that at the bare minimum you
will probably have your flying
privileges suspended the FAA takes these
things very seriously in addition to the
crew member requirements there's
something else you should know about
passengers who are under the influence
except in an emergency no pilot of a
civil aircraft may allow a person who
appears to be intoxicated or who
demonstrates by manner of physical
indications that the individual is under
the influence of drugs except as a
medical patient under proper care to be
carried in that aircraft
so if you suspect that your body is high
because he's showing any kind of
physical indications you are required to
leave his butt on the ground if you
don't and you get caught you could
potentially pay the price for his
stupidity in addition to all this far
6115 has a few additional requirements
if you're ever convicted of a drug or
alcohol offense while driving a vehicle
if you're convicted of any drug or
alcohol fence while driving a vehicle
you need to let the FAA know as soon as
possible you are required to send a
written report to the FAA civil aviation
security division within 60 days of a
conviction you'll find the address in
this reg if you need it now if you end
up needing this check out this
regulation for the most complete
information but basically if you drive
all intoxicated and paired or under the
influence of drugs or alcohol you are
required to let them know even if you
weren't under the influence when it
happened if you're convicted of any
motor vehicle fence and drugs or alcohol
were involved at all you need to let
them know about that as well so if you
run a stop sign and you had drugs in the
car you need to notify them yes there's
a chance you could get your flying
privileges suspended but if you ever
want the chance of getting those back
you need to notify them if any of these
things happen to you
in addition to all that if you decide
you want to enter the drug industry and
you get convicted for possessing making
transporting Distributing or the sale of
drugs you can basically kiss your flying
privileges goodbye this applies to
narcotics marijuana depressants
stimulants and other substances if you
get involved with these or if you're
convicted for operating an aircraft
under the influence of drugs or alcohol
you will most likely have your
certificate suspended or revoked and I
know how hard you're working on these
things don't throw them away by being
stupid I hope you learned something from
today's lesson on the Private Pilot
safety regulations please smash like if
you learned something from today's video
in my next video I'm going to talk about
all the stuff you need to know as far as
aircraft maintenance is concerned when
that video is finished I'll put it right
here in the meantime if you're
struggling with Landings in this video
I've got 10 tips that are going to help
you improve those Landings I'll see you
over there
you're not going to believe this I just
bought a free pilot training I'm going
to keep on watching